the hands already here
Outdoors what's up
John April hello what's up
what's up guys
how is everyone's there
I need a new chair this one's squeaking
like crazy
you down to your last bowl use your one
awesome I'm very sorry
[Applause]
what's up
the homie gummy Hello Elijah dela Rosa
hello hello where we smoke a city kid I
got some
purple Octane and I think there's some
left to this elephant
you're watching at Papa John's high off
a jam nice
I like that guwop Savage hello Devin
Halverson was so
your birthday is June 1st nice Rosie's
birthday is June I mean July 5th
sorry your birthday is July 5th you said
July 1st
I'm stumbling over my words what's up
so guys I just got the treadmill feeling
a little good today
chilling
the name of the [__] that gave me an
anxiety attack
OG with some OG's when you left
Rosie killed it it's all good
[Applause]
[__] it's all good
it's okay
okay hold on
give me one second guys
all right
is this by Hash House no that's not by
Hash House this one is
704 what up what up cam this chair is
squeak in
all right new chairs time for new chairs
this is this is terrible
do you smoke UK weed yet
definitely
fat dad
Antioch I got you
Johnny Figueroa I'll give you 280 what's
up
young KB gotcha you need a game chair I
took my good chairs to the podcast these
ones these ones suck okay
let's Heat this [__] up let's take a
fatter Factor Dad home assistant
oh
my favorites are just dumb empty
hold on this is the black cam from Hash
House this [__] is unbelievable
the turp is so overpowering it's hard to
take fat dabs
that one's done
missed missed completely
scrape this real quick too
[Applause]
no my favorite one no I didn't finish
these is what I meant my favorite ones
and I didn't finish them but it's okay
not a good deal that's all that's left
all right here we go
Marty is in Buffalo New York right now
Marty is not in California right now
okay hold on
you're a [__]
what's up
first time he's been there 10 years yeah
got a bunch of different hash
so what we'll do purple octane
I thought I was out of it
I'm gonna be honest
I was so hurt right now when I saw that
it was completely antique it is empty it
is a full [__] jar unopened
oh it's opened it's okay though
all right let's do this oh let's go all
right
what a morning
good afternoon
I'm so hyped right now
I thought it was gone guys
all right make it Yola flavored path
Tucker hello
I always say your name wrong
this episode is a 2 45 Long
it's episode almost three hours on guys
oh my God right was not working
yesterday
I might be on the fritz
is there against no no guess today
foreign
black cam
there we go
oh Marty's in here I missed it I missed
it
[Music]
there we go black came to start the day
thank you
foreign
[Music]
wow
yeah that was a good one
[Music]
actually I think about John was supposed
to be here at 12 what a jerk
nice that one that one got me
now I'm back what's up guys
shook it in water now
foreign
okay here we go
that was a good one
all right here we go
soak it in the water
Cody
that's
that's what I'm going for
John is literally black Wayne still
didn't show up on time you're completely
right all right podcast is dropping
right now almost a three hour episode of
me and Marty just hanging out and
talking this is rant City at its finest
thank you guys so much for being here
appreciate you have a dope ass day go to
the uh podcast drop it in one minute